Nhất là chúng ta, miếng kêu rất kỳ,
để chuyển lỗi cái cách tức mình là
từ việc là lo khó sở như về nhà,
sang là bú chi,
quyền có nhận,
từ là tiếp cạnh nếu ai mà thú đọc chưa thể bú chi được cho việc sở như nhà,
thì có thể tiếp cạnh nguồn cho tuyệt,
ra hả và ra cạnh hợp lý.
Chủ tưởng Le Ming Hương, nếu yêu cầu này,
tại cuộc làm việc với hải phòng, quảng linh,
bắt ninh, ninh, bình và hương in,
về phát triển nhà ở cho推,
chưa mùi một tình sấu.
Theo các địa phương,
quan công nhà ở cho推 hiện còn thấp sau với nhiều cầu,
phần lớn công nhân vẫn phải推 nhà cho tự phát,
trong khi nhiều quy nhà và tại sản công chưa được khai tháng hiệu qua.
Đối đây, một sĩ rửa bả hiểu kiểu vào gáo,
các có tình của người nguyện lưu xưa,
lột nào,
là chúng ta không gọi là nhà ở xa vội,
chúng ta sẽ qua cách phần cục,
là nhà ở thương mại để bán,
nhà ở chính xác,
nhà ở công vụ,
và nhà ở cho thôi,
ở trong nhà ở nước mạng để bán sẽ có nhiều cấp lộ khác nhau.
Tuy theo như cầu ở thương nhập để đắt hương và hiệu cầu.
Gợi dậy pháp vi đồng vốn,
tụi đứng cho biết,
nhà nước có thể chực tiếp xe,
hoặc vi đồng dân tiếp xe,
cho phép sắc định tỷ lệ nhà ở cho推,
thuộc sử hiểu nhà nước trong các dự án thương mại,
để tận dụng hạ tân.
Thì dụng một số các địa trung tâm,
thương mại,
để họ tạo tiền,
cóm với tiền tuy,
để họ có thể là vừa đàn bảo gái chí phí và thành và bảo phương.
Và thứ 2,
nữa là thánh bóan nửa đàn bảo được gái chí phí và đồ đứa.
Mà xây nghĩ tôi này này có con xây nghĩ của là bán phải của chân nữa.
Để cho thôi,
cho đúng đúng đứa.
Tụi đả chỉ đảng người hành nữa.
Nghận này,
bây giờ nghe hành,
chỉ sẽ xác sà hồ,
nghe chia,
không phải chỉ cho bây hơi đi vây của người nha đâu,
với đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy đầy.
Tụi đứng chỉ đạo trong thẳng sấu,
hải phòng, quảng nình, bác nình,
nình, bình, và hương een,
phấn đống hợi công ít nhất một giữa an nhở ở cho thôi.
Các giữa an nhở ở cho thôi,
có quy mô lớn sẽ chìn khai trong quy bà, quy bốn.